washington réunissent à nouveau ses
alliés ce mardi sur une base américaine
située en allemagne objectif là encore
armer davantage l'ukraine on en parle
avec vous guy leur traque vous êtes
notre correspondant à kiev bonjour à
vous le cren qui reçoit donc enfin une
aide qui est à la hauteur de ses besoins
moi ça approche d'une aide qui serait à
la hauteur de ses besoins l'ukraine je
pense n'est jamais complètement
satisfaite et voudrait toujours que ses
partenaires occidentaux
elle lui fournissent encore plus en
terme d' armes mais clairement si
sergueï lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe agite le spectre d une
guerre nucléaire c'est parce qu'il veut
décourager les alliés de lucre est de
continuer à terme et ce pays mais les
armes d'après le président volodymyr
zelensky sont maintenant des armes
lourdes qui arrivent notamment des temps
que la pologne hier a confirmé avoir
envoyé des tanks en ukraine faisant
suite à la république tchèque qui l
avait déjà fait il ya quelques quelques
jours ce sont là des armes d'époque
soviétique qui sont plus faciles pour
les ukrainiens d'utiliser ils ont
l'expérience et anthony blinken et lloyd
austin lorsque leur visite à kiev on dit
que les etats-unis aussi fournir des
munitions pour des armes soviétiques que
l'ukraine utilise en ce moment cela est
bien sûr en plus des armes plus moderne
que les etats-unis fournissent à
l'ukraine tout comme d'ailleurs le
royaume uni avec les haines lors ce sont
des armes anti tanks et la france avec
les armes anti tanks de type milan et
des auditeurs mais un haut placé
ukrainien à qui j'ai parlé hier a dit
que la france dispose
d'armes aussi plus sophistiquée qu'elle
pourrait fournir à l'ukraine et qu'ils
avaient espoir que maintenant l'élection
présidentielle française passée la
france commencerait à penser à ce
qu'elle pourrait faire en plus pour
aider l'ukraine et aussi bien sûr il ya
cette pression sur l'allemagne pour
augmenter son aide militaire à l'ukraine
une aide militaire qui pour les états
unis s'élèvent seuls les états unis je
veux dire s'élève à plus de 3 milliards
de dollars depuis le début de l'année
mais quand on parle de ses très grands
chiffres aux ukrainiens il rappelle
toujours le fait que ce chiffre est très
petit par rapport à ce qui est payé par
les pays européens pour acheter le gaz
et le pétrole russe qui est plusieurs
fois plus élevé que ce chiffre de 2,3
milliards
l'univers bonjour ou est-ce qu'on en est
sur la ligne de front à l'est et au sud
il n'y a pas beaucoup de progrès pour
les russes en tout cas dans sur le front
du donbass ni sur le front du sud les
attaques continuent mais les ukrainiens
10 d'avoir effectué des contre attaques
au moins dans la région de personnes
dans le sud du pays où ils affirment
avoir repris un petit peu de territoire
mais ce sont des informations qui
restent à confirmer
merci beaucoup glover vous étiez en
direct de kiev et sur le front est ce
vous en parliez